hi I'm Eric Voss and Netflix is the
punisher just released a new trailer and
oh man it looks wild now I'm gonna break
down all the details you might have
missed the deeper meaning of the song
choice Metallica's 1 and some clues
about the release date yeah I know
Netflix is being real coy about their
clever redaction imagery but the truth
must be taken in case you don't want too
much of that truth to be taken and you
want to be surprised when you watch The
Punisher spoiler warning like why are
you watching this video anyway let's get
started
[Music]
it's plenty of time not here home look
good Lord okay so this trailer opens
with these warm surreal flashbacks of
Frank castles family including some
shots of them on this carousel in
Central Park now in the comics central
park is a key location for castle it's
where his wife and kids were murdered
this carousel was also the setting for a
major Frank Castle fight in daredevil
season 2 however in the comics it was
the Mafia who killed his family for
witnessing a crime whereas it looks like
the TV version might be retcon to make
it more of a corrupt CIA black ops
assassination thing like that might be
why we see castles wife get killed in
his bedroom and these opening trailer
shots do some interesting visual tricks
that make me really excited for the way
the series is gonna look for example
notice the jump cut from castle teaching
his daughter to play guitar to castle
playing the guitar alone it's like for
castle each object abruptly triggers a
memory of what he lost
these Netflix Marvel shows have done a
lot of cool stuff with the color grading
and it looks like the Punisher will be
following suit notice these warm yellow
tones of these memories for Castle the
color yellow here signifies a safety and
comfort that was taken from him when his
family was murdered and of course we got
to talk about the music here these are
the opening notes of Metallica's one
from the injustice for all' album and
notice how they changed this opening
part from electric guitar to acoustic
mr. Riebe has seven massively and record
event
[Music]
and I think they did this to make these
opening images feel more reflective and
subdued which sets up a nice contrast to
win the more familiar metal sounds kick
in later and I'll get to this songs
deeper meaning when we get there but
let's move on
[Applause]
[Music]
shoot on sight
[Music]
okay in this section we get this
establishing shot of Hell's Kitchen New
York and I was talking about the use of
color earlier take a look at the sky
here those warm yellow tones from before
are now being overtaken by these blue
storm clouds in daredevil season two
castle was often color graded with blue
as a way to visually contrast him with
Daredevils red cones and this cityscape
shot is showing how castles emotional
storm is looming over Hell's Kitchen now
you probably notice how this trailer
features some awesome sound editing with
the clicks and pops of castle loading
and firing his weapons inked with Lars
Ulrich drumbeats from the song now this
kind of editing has been showing it more
and more in trailers lately like you may
remember it from the Suicide Squad
trailer and the Justice League trailer
but I like how in this case the editing
is actually inspired by the theme of the
music when co-writing this song James
Hetfield from Metallica said they were
actually inspired by a machine gun and I
love castles line here the fact that
he's responding to them right now means
that he's hacked into their radio
frequency listening in kind of like the
way John McClane does and diehard this
actually might be connected to that
other promo footage we saw with Mike
Rowe and castle hacking into the
soldiers body cams and pausing real
quick on this awesome
upward shot of castle with the Punisher
skull shirt notice the two holes in the
skull now I love how these bullet holes
with the bullet stopped at Cassie's vest
end up becoming part of this skull
design it's almost like castles head has
a few dings and scars on it but that
just becomes part of his armor as a
character okay let's move on covert CIA
operation
mainly George wants to eat that
everybody's fired to this ok this
section gives us more context for the
story of this season this bald guy is
Rollins he's the shady head of the CIA
unit that's targeting Castle now in the
comics Rollins is a CIA guy who's
committed a whole bunch of war crimes
he's pretty awful and in the show
universe it sounds like he might be
previous partners with the blacksmith
the villain Castle targeted in season 2
of daredevil now looking at these
interrogation images it appears that
Castle is being tortured with these
blunt tools like a hacksaw and pliers
and a blowtorch and it looks like he's
reliving this memory by watching it on
footage on micros computer and notice
how it's under the file names ooh by ear
interrogation now I don't really know
what Zoo by ear refers to maybe it's
some mission location where castles old
unit was sent or some CIA codename
anyway this whole dark government
conspiracy sounds like it'll be the
driving force of the narrative with
Castle uncovering the mystery with the
help of micro the hacker whistleblower
figure in the comics he goes by the name
microchip and I'll be tuning up again
with Karen Paige I assume she'll be
using her journalistic skills who shed
light on this whole mystery and it
actually looks like multiple government
agencies are part of this conspiracy
including the Department of Homeland
Security it looks like we'll be
introduced to the DHS through this new
character Dina Madani and if you look
closely here you can see Ben Barnes's
character coming out of the elevator now
he's playing Billy Russo aka jigsaw
who's Punishers arch-nemesis from the
comics he's named jigsaw because he used
to have this pretty boy face until
Punisher drove his face through a window
and left him with all these scars but in
this series he's gonna be a private
contractor a mercenary and head of the
anvil corporation and before I move on
I'm getting some major Logan vibes from
this shot of castle bloodied up in front
of the sink
remember Logan's first trailer also
began with an acoustic cover of a metal
rock song I heard myself
today and judging from the tone of this
Punisher trailer it seems like this show
is being inspired by Logan's gritty
redemptive story arc moving on you and
me we want the same thing stop work with
me
[Music]
okay so after this great introduction of
micro the action picks up here I think
my favorite move in this section is
castle using the fire hose to plunge
down a stairwell which seems like a
combination of two figures that might be
inspiring castles character this season
I mentioned John McClane before but yeah
this is another thing that he doesn't
die hard but also Jason Bourne from the
Bourne Identity and yeah if you think
about it John BIRT Thals Frank Castle is
kind of a mix of this New York City
antihero operating outside of the law
but also a former blackops assassin on
the run from these same organization
needs to work for it we also hear
Metallica's intense bridge section of
the song which brings us to the deeper
meaning of one
[Music]
so these lyrics are from the point of
view of a world war one soldier who lost
his limbs from a landmine as well as his
hearing sight and speech so he develops
a system to tap Morse code to the
hospital staff to just let him die and
yeah this is super dark but this is
exactly the type of PTSD Castle is
suffering from psychologically his
trauma has left him in a state where he
doesn't really feel alive he's just
stuck in this living hell which yeah
it's kind of a downer but it'll be cool
to see a character with real motivation
let's move on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow okay in this section notice how
castle never stops moving he just takes
headshot after headshot I feel like this
action was inspired by the John wick
movies which have a similar fluid
movement to them there's also a quick
shot of blood splashing on the carousel
horse now this shot seems super
impressionistic to me kind of like that
shot of castles wife getting executed I
have a feeling that both of these shots
are gonna end up being surreal nightmare
visions for castle rather than literal
flashbacks showing how his family
actually died check out this roar that
burnt the hull lets out as he gets
really pissed off at this pillar Jon
Bernthal might be my favorite casting
choice of all the characters in the
Netflix Marvel properties unlike some of
the pretty boys that Marvel has gone
with in the past
purple it's so good about conveying this
raw brute rage and marine precision that
we need to see in the Punisher character
like I'm legit scared of this guy okay
let's move into this final section Frank
castles back The Punisher is dead just
look like the work of a dead man
[Music]
okay so in this last bit we get a cameo
by Detective Brett Mahoney glad to see
him returning now take a look at the
room that he's in here this looks like
the same location at least I'll blow up
earlier in the trailer by the way I love
that that blast flipped a heavy two
seater feet in the air but on the coffee
table the flowers are still standing now
to me it looks like Karen Paige was in
that room maybe it was someone else
again if it was her maybe she was
talking to some protected government
source for a story
I don't see why Castle would want to
attack Karen so I'm thinking this could
be Rousseau or Rollins trying to kill
the story and the people writing it by
making it look like one of punchers acts
of terror now the final thing we see is
this mysterious release date 2017 with
the month and day redacted now as much
as I love this visual motif of censored
top-secret government documents and all
of these Punisher promo art pieces this
is killing me like there's only three
months left in 2017 might hold out on us
like this now at first I thought maybe
some of those flashing numbers or
letters could form a code that reveals
actual date and maybe they do but I
don't have time for that so let's just
think logically about this now I'm
assuming Netflix wouldn't be releasing
the Punisher in the month of October
it's a little soon and it would steal
some of stranger things Thunder season -
stranger things comes out on October 27
so that would push things back to
November now a Netflix series tend to
drop on Fridays and November 3rd is the
premiere of Thor Ragnarok and I just
don't think Marvel would want to compete
with himself like that and then two
weeks after that November 17th is the
premiere of Justice League and I don't
think Marvel would want to compete with
that either so with November 24th being
the Thanksgiving holiday I think that
leaves November 10th there's a solid
guest for the release date it's actually
a really appropriate day because it's
right before Veterans Day November 11th
and November 10th is the birthday of the
Marine Corp it's looking pretty good but
I'm sure we'll find out for sure soon
enough do you think the Punisher could
be the best Marvel Netflix series this
trailer does make it look really
promising and I have high hopes that it
can restore the brand back to its roots
weigh in in the comments below or by
tweeting me Addie Ava or you can follow
the new rock stars on Twitter at new
rockstars for updates on our videos
share this video and subscribe to this
channel for more videos about Marvel
news and if you really like us you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our current donors especially
Pony Stark all right thanks for watching
bye